هنا في مطار الفلوج الجنوبي السودان يفترش
الالاف من الفارين من الاشتباكات في
السودان الارض
الحزن والسخط يبدوان على وجههم
حيث يشتكون من المعامله السيئه من
القائمين على امر طرحهم
بعضهم وصف الوضع بالموت البطيء دم البطيء
بلدك
تتحالف فوقه وتتبهدل فيه ما احسن شلوط
تتحالف البلد مع بلدك الاوضاع الانسانيه
والمعيشيه تبدو سيئه للغايه
حيث يتعرض غالبيتهم الى ساعات الشمس
الحارقه واحيانا يعانون من حصول الامطار
ولسان حالهم يقول
رحلون من هنا قبل ان نموت
الرساله بتاعنا بس يعني
طريقه بس يصفرونا برا من هنا لانه هنا ده
ما في مويه اكل ما في يعني ناس قاعدين هنا
ومتجهين وكده ناس تعبانين حتى شوفوا شوفوا
صغير مثلا او الناس كلهم المطر هكذا يبدو
الوضع في مطار الفلوجه حيث افترش الجميع
الارض وعيونهم تراقب اي طائره تحبط على
هذا المدرج
مسؤول الاقاثه اعترفوا بان هناك تقصيرا هو
تجاوزات حدثت في مطارف اللج
وان السلطات الحكوميه والمدنيه ستعمل
جاهده على معالجه الامر بتوفير الطعام
وتكثيف الرحلات الى جباه الشركان ما قصروا
حاجه تانيه حاجه
بتقول لوزير الواجهه اللي منظمات عشان
اجيب الاكل لنسبه للنازل قاعدين في المطار
هنا اذا هي معاناه اخرى تواجه الالاف من
الفارينه من اصوات الرصاص والعالقين في
هذا المطار فاذا لم تسارع السلطات المعنيه
بطرحيلهم
فان الاوضاع مرشحه للاسوا
لله العربيه مطار فلوجه جنوب السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات